I really enjoyed Disney's live-action Beauty
And The Beast and I loved the way it even
acknowledged and fixed some plot holes and
mistakes from the original animated movie,
but hidden in the new movie is another bunch
of new mistakes.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this video, I'm going to break down
all the movie mistakes, goofs and plot holes
I spotted in Disney's 2017 Beauty And The
Beast.
And if you'd like a chance to win this beautiful
hardback book "Tale as Old as Time: The Art
And Making of Beauty And The Beast", all you
need to do is subscribe, and leave a comment
about the movie, and also answer the question
I'll be asking later in the video.
Quick warning there are some spoilers ahead
if you haven't seen the film.
The movie's remake of the opening song "Belle"
is a lot of fun, but it still has its share
of continuity and logic errors!
For starters, there's something rather wrong
with the town clock bells as they ring 7 of
the 8 bells before the clock has struck eight.
Belle then goes to pet one of the horses.
Look carefully at the double loop of rope
around the horse's face which as Belle turns
to Monsieur Jean magically becomes a single
loop.
Next, Belle goes over to Monsieur Jean and,
out of thin air, appears to conjure an apple,
which she gives to his donkey.
However, if you look at Belle's skirt as she
leaves, there doesn't appear to be a pocket
on the right-hand side of her dress where
the apple seemed to come from.
And the knot tied around Monsieur Jean's donkey
also changes when going from this wide shot
to a close-up shot of Belle feeding him the
apple.
Now, keep your eye on the baguette Belle bought
from the baker which she put in her skirt
pocket, because as we get to the next scene,
whoops the bread is gone!
This particular mistake might be explained
by a scene which was deleted from the final
movie, in which Belle gives the beggar woman
Agathe, aka the Enchantress, a loaf of bread
and a pot of jam.
Unfortunately, though, even taking into account
that deleted scene, this is still a mistake
because the baguette still disappears too
early in the song.
For example, here where Belle buys the jam,
which she later gives to Agathe with the bread
in the deleted scene, the bread is already
missing.
I don't know, maybe Marie stole the baguette
in protest at not getting a mention in the
new movie's opening song.
Belle's skirt is also a source of more continuity
errors.
Notice when she starts the song "Belle", her
skirt is hitched up on her right hand-side
revealing some of the white petticoat underneath.
The skirt stays hitched up through the song
until Belle enters the priest's library where
it's suddenly down.
As she entered the library, her hand did seem
to move towards her skirt, but that was the
opposite side of where the skirt was hitched
up, and I suspect she was just reaching into
one of her skirt pockets for the book she
mentioned she was returning to Pere Robert.
There's a funny moment when Gaston's horse
kicks mud all over the three lasses, ruining
their pink dresses.
However, when LeFou goes over to tell them,
"It's never going to happen ladies", some
of the mud stains seem to have miraculously
disappeared.
Maurice and Belle's horse, Philippe, is also
at the centre of several mistakes in the movie.
The first one occurs when Maurice is attacked
by the wolves and Philippe bolts with his
harness and chains still attached.
But, when Philippe returns to save Maurice
just before the wolves get him, he no longer
has them.
Next, after Maurice is captured by Beast at
the enchanted castle, Philippe gets away and
runs back home to Belle, arriving dirty and
muddy.
Belle understands something has happened and
tells Philippe to take her to her father,
except that when we see Belle riding, Philippe
is clean again.
Of course, it seems very unlikely Belle would
have stopped to clean Philippe as she was
rushing to look for her missing father.
Later, when Maurice leaves the castle, we
don't see how he gets back to the town.
Philippe is still at the castle when Belle
flees and gets attacked by the wolves, so
Maurice didn't take Philippe with him.
In the original animation, Maurice was sent
back on an enchanted carriage, but in the
live-action remake, his return to town remains
a mystery.
When Belle arrives at the castle she runs
up a staircase in a clockwise direction.
Notice how she's holding the candlestick in
her right hand, which is closest to the inside
wall of the stairs.
As she emerges at the top of the staircase,
her right hand and candlestick are closest
to the outside wall and she's now running
anti-clockwise.
Back in town, Gaston gets to perform his big
number, but just as LeFou starts singing Gaston's
knife handling reveals a continuity error.
Watch carefully how his right hand moves from
the hilt of the knife in this shot to all
way down the blade near the tip when LeFou
is singing and the shot changes angle.
Also during the song, Gaston shoots into the
ceiling, and a small pile of debris falls
down.
The song then continues, but from this camera
angle, the debris is no longer there.
The live-action version of "Be Our Guest"
is just fantastic yet there are still a couple
of mistakes in there.
The guillotine-based joke that Lumiere makes
when he chops a baguette is anachronistic
as the guillotine wasn't common in France
until the late 18th century, whereas the movie
is actually set in the mid-18th century.
Although the blade in the film is a bread
guillotine, Lumiere says "This Is France"
as he chops the bread, and the guillotine
is, of course, closely associated with the
French Revolution.
Also the chopped baguette piece falls into
a little basket similar to how heads did after
executions.
And on the menu, there's another French slip-up
with the Potato dishes, with a spelling mistake
on "Pommes De Terre".
The "terre" is spelled incorrectly with an
"s" on the end.
And when Lumiere introduces the dishes, he
mentions various plates that are supposed
to appear on Belle's menu including Beef Ragout,
Cheese Soufflé, Pie and Pudding en Flambé,
except that Cheese Soufflé isn't on the menu,
it's Camembert Grillé.
When Belle and Beast go for a walk in the
castle grounds, she recites a line from a
poem called A Crystal Forest, which goes as
follows: 'each blade of grass seems clad miraculously
with glass'.
That poem was penned by a Scottish writer
called William Sharp, who was born in 1855
and died in 1905.
However, as this movie is set in the mid-1700s,
there's no way Belle could have known a poem
which hadn't been written yet!
The owl we see with Agathe as she's nursing
Maurice gives a little hoot.
However, the type of owl is actually a barn
owl and barn owls make screechy type of noises
rather than the typical hoots you might expect
from other types of owl.
After Belle and Maurice break out of the asylum
wagon, Belle rides off to the castle dumping
her yellow dress as she leaves.
She's obviously in a hurry as she knows Beast
is in danger, but during the ride back to
the castle she acquires a sweater, which doesn't
quite make sense because she got rid of it
later anyway and surely she wouldn't have
taken the time to go home and pick up something
new to wear?
So, what other movie mistakes, goof or plot
holes did you spot in Beauty And The Beast?
And how do you think the movie compared with
the original animation?
To enter the giveaway for this gorgeous hardback
book "Tale as Old as Time: The Art And Making
of Beauty And The Beast", make sure you're
a subscriber, and leave a comment about the
movie, and also answer the following question:
"What dish did Lumiere sing about in 'Be Our
Guest' that didn't appear on Belle's menu?"
If you enjoyed this video, don't forget to
give it a thumbs-up and why not take a look
at these 10 movie mistakes that the new Beauty
And The Beast fixed from the animated classic
or more of my Disney videos below!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers.